heute geht es ums thema einkochen und
ich möchte mein allerliebstes einfach
rezept mit euch teilen das sind die
zonen die schmecken super toll zu
milchreis zu griesbrei was ich auch
super gern mache ist ein blumenkübel
oder zweiten kombi ihr könnt ihr frommen
oder zwei zu verwenden ist komplett egal
nehmen das was ihr da hat dafür lebe ich
einfach die flammen aus dem glashaus
oder die zwetschgen läge die in einer
backform oder auflaufform und dann mache
ich streusel und krümel lieder drüber
und dann gebe ich das ganze in den ofen
und 20 minuten später hat man ein super
leckeren kuchen obwohl es eigentlich gar
keinen kuchen ist den man aber wunderbar
auch gästen vor setzen kann wo man ganz
ganz schnell was auf den tisch zaubern
kann was wirklich sehr sehr sehr lecker
isst man kann natürlich auch eine
normale zwetschgenkuchen damit machen
nicht es die auch total gerne in joghurt
kriegen wir alle noch jung und liebe
anfang mit dem rezept ich habe euch ja
versprochen dass ich dieses video so
filme dass jeder das mitmachen kann egal
ob ihr das ein koch zubehör bei euch zu
hause habt oder nicht ihr könnt einen
ganz normalen großen kochtopf verwenden
um dieses rezept einzukochen ihr könnt
einfach supermarkt altglas verwenden das
heißt alte honiggläser alte
marmeladengläser saure gurken leser über
die gut aus was dass sie nicht immer
noch saure gurken schmecken usw
da könnt ihr wirklich einfach die sachen
verwenden die ihr zuhause da habt das
einzige was sehr wichtig ist ist dass
ihr wenn ihr schraubt der kiw verwendet
schaut dass die nicht verbaut sind weil
sonst kann sich dahinter her kein vakuum
in dem glas bilden und die frau bayern
ziemlich schnell da also rigoros
aussortieren also waren wir gleich an
und starten mit dem zum rezept losgeht
an zutaten brauchst du anderthalb kilo
pflaumen oder zwetschgen 200 gramm
zucker und zimt nachgeschmack
ansonsten brauchst du ein kocht leser
egal ob weckgläser oder schraubgläser
aus dem supermarkt ein tuch zum
abwischen falls mal was daneben geht
einen trichter und eine schöpfkelle und
eine sache ist noch super super
praktisch und zwar so ein glas heber mit
dem kannst du die gläser dann aus
im heißen wasser rausheben zuallererst
packe ich alle gummiringe und alle decke
in einen topf lebte einen schuss essig
dazu und wasser und koche das ganze
brodelt auf die sollten fünf minuten
lang brodelt kochen und dann erhitze ich
auch das wasser und setzte die
zuckerlösung an
du brauchst für das rezept 600
milliliter wasser für die 200 gramm
zucker das einfach schön miteinander
verrühren und aufkochen lassen nicht
wundert ich mach mir hier in dem video
so dass ich das rezept multipliziert
habe das kannst du natürlich auch machen
und dann den zimt dazu geben einfach
nach geschmack ich geb dir jetzt für
fünf kilo zweite ich ungefähr zwei
esslöffel mit ins wasser
aber das kannst du einfach abschmecken
und so machen wie du es am liebsten hast
du kannst auch weniger zucker verwenden
oder mehr zucker je nachdem wie du es
gerne hast das ist für dieses rezept
nicht so wichtig wir werden das land
genug einkochen damit es trotzdem
sicherheit bald auch wenn du weniger
zucker verwendet dann die zwetschken
oder pflaumen einmal gut ab waschen und
halbieren ich beschneide die einfach in
hälften da sieht man auch auf höhe
zwetschgen matschig sind oder gammelig
sind die natürlich aus sortieren und
dann schichte ich die in die gläser und
zweischichtig die so darein dass sie mit
der aufgeschnittenen seite nach unten
zeigen dann sieht das ganze hinterher
etwas hübsches nachdem einkochen du
kannst sie aber auch wild durcheinander
einfüllen
ich drücke immer mal oben drauf damit
noch mehr im verein passen weil die
werden beim einkochen ein bisschen an
volumen verlieren so dass die gläser
dann nachher nicht mehr schön voll sind
wenn man jetzt nicht richtig anständig
auffüllt die modernen weg leser kannst
du bist ziemlich knapp und am rand
befüllen bei schraubte er sein solltest
du aber ungefähr 2 cm zum brandplatz
lassen dann die zuckerlösung in die
gläser einfüllen auch so hoch wie ich
eben gesagt habe also neue weckgläser
bis knapp unter brandt und bei
schraubgläser in ungefähr 2 cm platz
lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt brauchst du einen großen
kochtopf nimm einfach den größten
kochtöpfe den du hast wenn du einen
normalen ein kochtopf fast ist das
natürlich auch super dann im gehen ich
habe da jetzt ein geschirrtuch unten
rein gelegt und mit dem mit kochendem
wasser gefüllt bzw ganz kocht das wasser
nicht denn in unserem topf soll dieselbe
temperatur herrschen wie in den gläsern
also dass ungefähr aufeinander abstimmen
sodass ich das dann gleichmäßige
miteinander erhitzen kann und man genau
weiß wie die temperatur im glas inneren
denn genau ist da kommen dann die gläser
rhein am besten so einstellen dass sie
sich nicht berühren und dann cremig ein
thermometer unter den deckel da kannst
du einfach einen fleisch thermometer
verwenden ich habe einfach mein ein koch
thermometer genommen sodass man ablesen
kann wie die temperatur im wasser ist
dann den herd an stellen und warten bis
die temperatur auf 90 grad geklettert
ist und ab da an geht dann unsere ein
kochzeit jetzt darfst du also einen
teiler vor holen und ihr ein timer auf
30 minuten stellen in der einkauf zeit
sollte die temperatur nicht unter die 90
grad fallen und allein schon um
nährstoffe zu schonen ist es natürlich
immer viel besser wenn man es nicht
heißer gekocht als es denn unbedingt
sein muss wenn die 30 minuten abgelaufen
sind kannst du deine gläser aus dem topf
heben dafür eignet sich der glas lieber
eben wunderbar und dann stellst du dir
auf ein geschirrtuch und die klammern
entfernt du wenn die gläser komplett
abgekühlt sind so und damit wären wir
auch schon fertig einige von euch werden
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich wundern wieso
denn da noch die alte küche zu sehen war
das liegt daran dass gerade ein altes
video von mir gesehen habt und zwar ein
video aus der macht deine ernte haltbar
challenge 2020 das ist eine video
challenge die jedes jahr für einen
newsletter veranstalter wo ich ganz viel
über das klima haltbarmachen der ernte
spreche und euch tipps geben zum einen
wochen zum fermentieren auch rezepte und
eigentlich die neue teile in spe 2021
geplant habe fand ich es total schade
die alten
und videos aus zu schmeißen und deswegen
theilig das team flammen rezept was
wirklich als mit einer absoluten
lieblingsrezepte ist jetzt noch mal hier
auf dem kanal für euch ihr könnt euch
gerne für die macht eine ernte haltbar
challenge 2021 anmelden das ist völlig
kostenlos und das macht richtig viel
spaß da herrscht auch immer ganz toller
austausch und alle die lust haben ihre
fortschritte dieses jahr bis unter die
decke zu füllen sind herzlich eingeladen
den link packt euch da oben hin und auch
unten in die video beschreibung ich
spreche hier auf dem kanal ganz viel
über das thema gerd man aber immer auch
über das thema haltbar machen weil das
super wichtig ist wenn man im winter
immer noch ganz vielfältig und bunt aus
dem eigenen garten essen möchte und
deswegen habe ich schon einige videos
zum thema halt da machen hier
veröffentlicht dann packe ich jemals die
playlist hin wo ich die alle freuen soll
ich für euch geordnet habe dass ihr
damals stöbern können ansonsten geht
raus macht die welt ein bisschen grüner
aber macht auch eure fotos schränke ein
bisschen bunter und wir sehen uns am
samstag wieder umsehen für ein neues
video